[Applaudissements]
non mais qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous faites là vous êtes très très en
retard fallait installer
Albert il vous a pas dit que le temps
c'est très relatif non il y a pas de tu
viens quoi parce que là il faut y aller
elle est pas arrivée encore la princesse
voulu installer son petit poil là parce
que c'est une mamie donc il faut pas
qu'elle ait froid
il faut qu'elle soit bien installée
parce qu'on m'a dit elle va vous
raconter des histoires alors moi on m'a
dit de lui installer tout ce qu'il faut
voilà le fauteuil
le poil la petite bougie il faut que ça
soit bien pour pour raconter des
histoires son petit livre en façon gros
livre
bah voilà
bah écoute vas-y tu es toujours un peu
en retard toi aussi mais comme le temps
n'existe pas merci à toi
bon elle est là la princesse
pourtant qu'est-ce qu'on
planning on timing on zoom mon Zizou mon
manage on déménage
c'est le cas où vous le voyez c'est le
chaos
bon
vous êtes là
moi je suis là
alors
j'écoute en coulisses quand même et la
dame là il a dit elle a dit l'étoile
alors on va faire ça
on va faire ce qu'elle a dit
allez on va
aller chercher là
vous savez juste au-dessus du chaos de
votre chaos là
il y a un filet lumineux alors vous le
tirez voilà vous le déroulez bien bien
bien bien et puis une fois qu'il est
bien déroulé vous le lancez ah c'est pas
toujours du premier coup mais vous le
lancez vous l'accrochez à l'étoile et là
on est au rendez-vous
bah oui
voilà et bon après il faut dire que les
humains s'entendent pas toujours
sur le mode d'emploi
il y a plusieurs interprétations de la
notice
et ça fait un peu de
tracas sur la terre
mais moi je dis qu'il faut se défaire
vous voyez faut se défaire il faut se
défaire des apparences des de ces
costumes coutumiers
habituel dans lesquels on est finalement
enfermé
emprisonné étiqueté parce qu'on nous
prend pour ce comparer pas vrai alors
faut changer faut du mouvement parce que
sans ça le fil lumineux il bouge c'est
pas bon c'est pas bon du tout donc vous
voyez
là ça s'appelle une métamorphose
là c'est la technicienne et là
est-ce que ce n'est pas la princesse
[Applaudissements]
je suis la princesse conférencière et je
suis la technicienne
je suis la philosophe et je suis la
maman
je suis chef de chantier et je suis
écrivain comme chacun d'entre vous aussi
se caleridoscope infini qui constitue
l'humain appelle à émerger à ce que nous
explorions chacune de ces facettes on
tente on regarde on essaye on laisse
tomber
jusqu'à devenir
qui on est
mais d'abord
je vais vous raconter une histoire
une histoire qui peut-être permet de
comprendre
comment du chaos
on arrive à la plus grande cohérence
et à la joie
Sarajevo
1er octobre 1993
la guerre dure depuis plus d'un an
les enseignes des cafés pendent arrachés
les rideaux de fer sont tirés
la cathédrale se profile au bout de la
rue où se côtoient la synagogue la
mosquée une petite église orthodoxe
l'architecture parle ici de cohabitation
sereine de paix entre les religions
j'ai entendu que des bûcherons sont
venus couper du bois dans dans la ville
assiéger pour les otages
les infirmières sont venus penser les
blessures
moi je viens faire ce que je sais faire
ouvrir un atelier d'écriture et de
pratiques théâtrale
collecter dans l'abomination la grandeur
de l'humain
mais tout à coup je me sens décalé de
l'écriture du théâtre au cœur de combat
sanglant avec des enfants endeuillés
je marche je croise un blindé de l'ONU
blanc entité sourde et aveugle qui fonce
dans les rues vides
sur mon plan je vois que deux rhumes
permettent de rejoindre la place où j'ai
rendez-vous pour l'atelier l'une
et goudronnée l'autre sans doute plus
ancienne et pavée j'hésite
je choisis les pavés ils sont beaux
je marche
soudain un obus tombe
dans la rue voisine tout près la rue que
je n'ai pas emprunté
tout tremble et mon corps
il est question
affluent ce percute dans ma tête mais
qu'est-ce que je fais là pourquoi je
suis là pour l'art pour l'oeuvre à créer
que suis-je venu chercher et qui viendra
à ce rendez-vous anachronique pour
écrire et jouer une pièce de théâtre
ai-je perdu tout sens de la réalité et
mes enfants qui sont restés à Paris
et qu'elle parent laisseront leurs
enfants sortir des abris pour aller
rencontrer une inconnue
je marche
aux tomates au souffle court
la place du rendez-vous se dévoile
ils sont là
ils sont là debout dehors
ils n'ont pas couru aux abris de peur de
me rater me dire en t-il de rater le
rendez-vous
14 adolescents des arbres au bord de la
clairière
il me voit apparaître sur la place
déserte ils sont tendus vers moi cela
même qui ne me connaissent pas ceux-là
qui ne savent rien de moi un immense
sourire envahit leur visage
elle est vivante
elle
c'est moi
un moi qui n'a rien à prouver
à moi qui n'a en cet instant en commun
avec eux avec vous
que le fait d'être en vie
il nous est donné de vivre une rencontre
improbable nous avons cinq jours pour
écrire et monter la pièce ils n'ont
jamais écrit ils n'ont jamais joué il me
dévore des yeux il croit en l'impossible
et alors
l'impossible s'incline en une grande
révérence et s'efface pour laisser la
place au possible et au quatrième soir
je vois naître en répétition générale le
dictionnaire de la vie qui fera bientôt
tout le tour de la terre
ils apprend le même soir la mort de ma
mère
au cinquième jour nous jouons la pièce
dans trois quartiers de la Villa si j'ai
sous les bombardements et le public aux
risques de sa vie est au rendez-vous
l'avenir et debout
c'est instinct suspendu où l'oeuvre nous
a relié dans le rire et les larmes
c'est avec vous ce soir que je veux le
vivre
alors je vous prie comme je l'ai fait
avec ses adolescents je vous prie de
prendre dans le sac qui vous a été remis
une feuille blanche
un crayon un stylo
ou bien
l'application que vous avez téléchargé
en début d'après-midi
et ainsi
de poser quelques mots
quelques mots de votre vie
une peine
une toute petite peine ou une grande
peine une douleur peut-être enfouie
un chagrin d'enfants une peine à
partager avec nous ce soir mais aussi
avec tous les disparus avec ceux qui
sont tout autour de la Terre parce que
partager la peine est tellement plus
légère
n'ayez aucune crainte vos mots
demeureront anonymes écrivez en toute
liberté
une émotion un souvenir qui si ce soir
resurgit le nom d'un disparu écrivez
[Musique]
pour ceux qui écrivent sur du papier
quelques-uns vont passer parmi vous
et m'apporter les feuilles
l'écorce de ces arbres devenus papiers
pour poser ses mots qui vont nous relier
qui vont s'accrocher au fil d'un
lumineux
[Musique]
je vais à présent donner aussi ma voix à
vos mots pour qu'ils veulent l'un à
l'autre comme des oiseaux je ne pourrais
pas tout lire car ici encore
contrairement à l'étoile le temps nous
est compté
mais tous les mots je les rassemblerai
dans un recueil que vous pourrez
retrouver
[Musique]
mon souvenir le plus marquant
le décès de mon parrain
[Musique]
on inquiétude
la santé de papa
[Musique]
le lilas
une envie profonde de libération
la perte de mon aimer
la naissance de ma fille
la naissance de mon premier fils
l'accident
[Musique]
mon grand-père tu me manques
mon père tu me manques
je te veux dans ma vie
un mariage raté
[Musique]
l'accident de voiture avec des tonneaux
alors qu'à bord il y avait tous mes
enfants
toi mon amour
ma petite maman partie trop tôt
la perte de ma maman à l'âge de deux
mois
maman
[Musique]
le conflit avec ma famille et mes
parents
les naissances de mes défis
[Musique]
tu aimais
la naissance de ma fille Marie-Louise
le jour où j'ai saisi le sens profond de
la liberté
les liens
Adrien dans mes bras à sa naissance
[Musique]
ce que vous venez d'entendre
c'est l'humain vrai
sincère
dépouillé de ses habits de fête de ses
habits de préjugés de certitudes qui
nous sépare c'est l'enchantement
[Musique]
in
cantare c'est la racine latine de
l'enchantement
[Musique]
in au dedans
cantare chanter
c'est ce chant du dedans qui embellit
nos vies
[Musique]
nous permet d'être très d'union entre la
terre et le ciel
pour accueillir l'ordre du cosmos et
réenchanter
notre chaos
vous êtes les auteurs les acteurs les
metteurs en scène de votre vie tous les
jours vous écrivez votre histoire qui
s'inscrit dans la grande histoire de
l'humanité
pour se poser
dans l'écrin de l'œuvre
la plus belle qui soit
l'oeuvre de vie
à présent levez-vous levez-vous
[Musique]
plantez les bras vers les étoiles
sentez la jubil
ation
du monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]